I have to move on right now
all right you are all stop saying that
the two-tier debate format is turning
the Republican presidential race into a
reality TV show no it's more like the
Westminster Kennel Club dog show you
know where the dogs compete in separate
categories the big dogs that bark a lot
and slobber and the small dogs that wear
sweaters and friends new role the makers
of the pot of gold at the it's real
folks real the makers of the pot of gold
at the end of the rainbow st. Patrick's
Day cookie cutter have to stop wondering
why the cookies come out soft
it's not you honey it's st. Patrick's
Day a guy is a little too much to drink
it could happen to anyone
have a cookie no rule let Bill Cosby
keep his Medal of Freedom
but maybe put a bell in it neural
experts must assure the Conservatives
who think this video of President Obama
in Kenya shows a demon racing across the
screen up but let's see that again oh oh
definitely that was absolutely a demon
that was I was not an out-of-focus boom
microphone no it was a hideous demon
right from hell and Friends the only way
to get rid of a demon like that is by
sending your prayers along with a check
to lighthouse ministries care of the
Reverend William oh that's lighthouse
ministries for care of the Reverend
William R remember the more you give the
quicker that demon will get noose
god bless new rule people posting
emotional tearjerker videos on Facebook
have to come up with a more original
tagline than get your tissues ready I'm
sure it warns women that they're about
to have a good cry but when a man sees
get your tissues ready he's thinking of
something else desire
ah
you